[Music]
[Music]
good morning
it's seven o'clock now after that
devastating testimony from dominic
cummings today
we get the government fight back the
health secretary matt hancock will face
mps this morning
to answer claims he lied to colleagues
and should have been
fired on at least 15 occasions in a
moment the housing secretary robert
generic will respond to accusations made
by mr cummings yesterday and after eight
we'll hear from labour's deputy leader
angela rayner
also this morning
roll about your feet and your fingers go
and get your feet
a new recruit the movement tackles a
dramatic fall in membership
because of the pandemic and he's the
scientist who can explain
complex astrophysics in the origins of
the universe to
well just about anyone neil degrasse
tyson joins us
at 9 45 it's thursday the 27th of may
a personal fight back the health
secretary is set to defend his record
after the pm's former aide says he
should have been sacked
for supposedly telling lies about covet
fighting the scourge police say they've
significantly reduced the number of
county lines gangs smuggling drugs
across the uk
drawn out drama man united lose a 22
penalty shootout in the europa league
final
and the weather's getting warmer for the
bank holiday weekend but the weather
news isn't
all good the details coming up shortly
you'll see the six of us in the same
room for the first time in
at least nine years if not 17. a lot of
laughs a lot of um
you know heartfelt moments and and it's
been
incredible and they'll be there for you
the one where the cast of friends
reunite
well a very good morning to you the
health secretary matt hancock is
expected to come out fighting when he
faces mps this morning
and holds a downing street news
conference later
his reputation was savaged by the prime
minister's former aide dominic cummings
who accused him of lying to colleagues
about the pandemic
and suggested there were 15 to 20
occasions when he should have been
sacked
boris johnson is also likely to face
questions when he visits a hospital
after mr cummings branded him unfit for
office
and said tens of thousands of people
didn't need to die
our chief political correspondent john
craig reports
fighting for his political life after
dominic cummings said he should be
sacked for lying
arriving home last night a defiant matt
hancock
was ready to fight back well i haven't
seen the uh
this performance today in full and
instead i've been dealing with getting
the vaccination rollout going especially
to over 30s and
and saving lives i'll be giving a
statement in
the house of commons and i'll have more
to say that he's answering an
urgent question from labour in the
commons and later leading a downing
street
news conference on vaccines when he
answers questions from mps mr hancock
will say
he absolutely rejects the claims made
about him
by mr cummings he'll say that both he
and the staff in his department have
worked incredibly hard during the
pandemic
to protect the nhs and save lives
at his downing street news conference mr
hancock will claim
fantastic progress is being made on
vaccines
with more than half a million people a
day now getting a jab
and boris johnson is visiting a hospital
today
to underscore the message of getting on
with the job
that he delivered in the commons
yesterday
in his bombshell evidence to mps mr
cummings claimed
tens of thousands of people died from
covid
who didn't need to die and that mr
johnson was unfit
to be prime minister fundamentally i
regarded him as unfit for the job
and i was trying to create a structure
around him to try and
stop what i thought were extremely bad
decisions and push other things through
against his wishes
tens of thousands of people died who
didn't need to die the problem in this
crisis was
very much lions led by donkeys over and
over again
but his most brutal attack was on mr
hancock
the secretary of state for health should
have been fired
for at least 15 20 things including
lying to everybody
in multiple occasions in meeting after
meeting in the in the cabinet room and
publicly
tory mps claim mr cummings is settling
scores
and are backing mr hancock what mr
cummings has said this title title from
yesterday was
really important for sky viewers and for
all the british population
is us getting fully out of this pandemic
but labour says mr hancock must answer
mr cummings allegations
anyone who has lost a loved one in this
awful crisis
will expect matt hancock to explain to
explain whether
dominic cummings is correct or whether
he's correct he's being accused of
failing to protect her homes he's being
accused of misleading the nation and the
most senior people
in government however i am aware that he
does have the right to give his side
of the story after more than seven hours
of evidence
mr cummings appeared to be pondering the
reaction to his allegations
as he paced up and down outside
parliament
but mr hancock insists he's not running
away
and his fight back begins later this
morning
john craig sky news
well as dominic cummings gave his
evidence the daily covert data revealed
the highest number of cases since
mid-april there were 3 180 new
infections reported and nine more deaths
that means the total number of people
who've died within 28 days of a positive
test is now 127
748. another 186
147 people had their first vaccination
and 387
987 had their second so in total
nearly 62 million injections have now
been administered
across the uk okay let's talk to the
housing secretary robert generic who
joins us now very good morning to you
did mr hancock lie to the cabinet and to
the public repeatedly well good morning
i'm not going to get into the
specific allegations that were made
we've heard one side of the story there
will be a full public inquiry
next year and that's absolutely the
right thing to do because people have
lost loved ones this has been
an incredibly difficult period for
everyone some people
much more profoundly than others what
the government must do
is keep on responding to the pandemic
you heard earlier the prime minister
is getting on with the job we're all
yeah but
it's no good you appearing on this
program and not being prepared to
to answer questions and with the
greatest of respect we've heard all
about what the government's doing with
the rollout
we hear that every single day and a lot
of people say it is
it is a very good thing but it what
people will take from your response to
that first answer
first question is it you're not prepared
to back the health secretary why not
why not well i think that the department
for health
and the health secretary have worked
exceptionally hard over the course of
this pandemic this was
an unprecedented situation it was a
national effort involving
all parts of government and all parts of
the country
i think the public will appreciate that
if you think back to
the events of this time last year how
challenging it really was
many things happen of course there'll be
things which we could have done
better and we're learning those lessons
as we go along the public inquiry
will air that and hear the evidence in a
reasoned and reflective
manner i think that is the right way to
do that but
absolutely i think the country responded
phenomenally
to the events of last year my point was
that we are still responding to the
pandemic and that has to be the focus of
government
right now yes well you are responding to
the pandemic but if we're going to have
any lessons
learned in moving forward and we'll talk
about the inquiry a bit more in a moment
but in terms of
learning lessons in the immediate term
we need to know don't we
whether you think the health secretary
lied to the cabinet on multiple
occasions
lied to the public on multiple occasions
i mean is that absolutely unfounded
well my that's not my experience my
experience having worked with the health
secretary and with the prime minister
last year were of people doing
everything that they could under huge
pressure
in a unique situation to try to steer
the country through
the pandemic and every turn trying to
act in the best interests of the whole
country
that's of course what we would have
expected of them and that's what they
did
were the things that we could have done
differently or better i'm sure that
there were
there were also many things that the
country got very right
the vaccine royal courses one of the
most prominent of them but there are
other examples
as well in my own department can i ask
you about all of the rough sleepers of
the country
off the streets within two weeks for
example yeah can i ask you about care
homes because that's a really
important issue we were told there was
going to be a shield
around care homes i mean that would you
know appear to mr cummings says the
government rhetoric
about the shield around care homes was
absolute nonsense
and we do know we you know we have hard
empirical data
about the number of deaths of people in
care homes
well i think the position of people in
care homes was extremely difficult
they were of course the most elderly and
often the most frail members
of society i think there are things we
with the benefit of hindsight could have
done better to protect people
in care homes we didn't of course know
all the things we know today about the
virus at the very beginning
for example we didn't know how
asymptomatic people were able to
transmit the virus or the extent that
they're able to transmit and that was an
important factor when we were weighing
up
discharging people from hospital and
returning them either to care homes or
to their own homes so there were things
that we learned along the way and i hope
that we learnt them as quickly
as we could taking the scientific advice
as it evolved
but we did make steps to protect people
in care homes as soon as
we could we did provide over three
billion pounds of funding to the sector
we did put in place uh care packages and
and measures so that people working in
care homes could careful and we went to
huge lengths
to get ppe to them that was very
challenging at times
and there were moments when people in
care homes felt that it was touch and go
but across the whole country we did
manage to get the ppe to the front line
so i don't think anybody is disputing
the fact that care homes are one of the
most difficult
elements of the last 12 months or so but
it's not correct to say that we didn't
do everything we possibly could to
protect
both the residents and the people who
work in the care homes
with the imperfect information that we
had available to us
at the time well apart from not testing
people who are being sent to care homes
which you think be pretty fundamental
well i think that's my point isn't it
that at the time
the very beginning of the pandemic the
scientific
advice wasn't what we know today which
is that
this is a virus which can transmit
asymptomatically
there was very little understanding of
that that was an unusual situation
had we known that at the beginning i
think we probably would have done
more to test people as they were leaving
hospital
before they went into care homes and
that's something that clearly we've
learned as we've gone along and
we're making sure that that doesn't
happen again but it's very easy to make
that judgment with hindsight that wasn't
the case at the time as you can see if
you read
the advice that ministers were receiving
if you read
the minutes of sage for example which
are all in the public domain
you'll see that our knowledge of the
virus was quite limited to begin with it
grew very rapidly thanks to
a fantastic team of scientific advisors
oh look there's no there's no doubt
hindsight is a wonderful thing but but
nevertheless
you know we've still got to look at in
detail about what happened i mean
you say the government was following
scientific advice
in september it's claimed the prime
minister was sort of the only person in
the room
uh amongst members of the cabinet and
amongst the advice giving by given by
the uh the chief scientific advisor
that there should be a second lockdown
the pm apparently just didn't want one i
mean
what were you thinking when you heard
the prime minister say that
amid the voices of everybody else
well all i can say is that at every time
the prime minister acted in the best
interest of the countries he saw it
and it's the job of the prime minister
to take a rounded view
weighing up the health advice the
economic advice
because remember lockdowns are very
damaging not just economically but
to public services to wider health and
well-being and that's the difficult job
that he does having to take that rounded
view
it was also not the case that everyone
was calling
for a lockdown of the kind that we went
into later
in the autumn remember many people were
asking for
a short two-week circuit breaker i think
it's pretty clear today that that would
not have succeeded
that was bad advice could we have gone
into
the kind of longer term lockdown that we
did slightly
perhaps but then of course we didn't
know about the variance
that we later learnt about and how
seriously transmissible they were
so i think these judgments are harder to
make at the time than you might imagine
of course with the benefit of hindsight
we're able to look back upon them and
these are things which will be weighed
up carefully i'm sure when we do come to
that public inquiry
well exactly i mean and that does need
to be obviously that public inquiry is
going to be absolutely crucial but when
we've got concerns over
indian variant we've got concerns over
potential other
variants coming forward because we know
they may well emerge
we've got concerns over potentially
something happening in the summer with
the rising cases we know there's concern
from the scientists over a winter surge
as well
why not have an inquiry now so that we
can learn the lessons
and be in a much better position for
anything that may happen later in the
year
well we are learning lessons we're
learning lessons as we go along we've
just discussed some of the
the lessons that we've learned such as
the fact that we didn't know at the
beginning
uh quite yet but why not hold on to
impact on the asymptomatic
we learned that as quickly as the
evidence became available we
adapted and evolved our strategy do i
think that holding a full public inquiry
right now whilst we're still responding
to the pandemic
whilst we're still grappling with some
of the issues you've just set out like
the new variants
like the when to reopen our economy how
we
recover public services no i don't think
that would be the sensible thing to do
i think next spring seems like a logical
time because hopefully the country will
be in a vastly
different and improved situation then
public inquiries
are lengthy processes we've seen that
with all the ones
in the recent past and they're better i
think to occur
when we're out of the immediate response
phase and then we can
take a reflective view look at the
evidence carefully
not just listen to individuals making
testimony as we heard yesterday
but look at the evidence in the round
and learn the lessons obviously for the
future
minister good to talk to you thank you
well we will have full coverage of matt
hancock's appearance in the house of
commons here on sky news that's this
morning from half past
ten we'll also bring you coverage of his
downing street news conference
which will be at five o'clock this
afternoon
i will comb through the details of
dominic cummings evidence at half past
seven this morning with a member of the
sage committee and a journalist who's
covered the career
of boris johnson
labour will give us their response to
those allegations we'll talk to their
deputy leader angela rainer at five
past eight and
tom templeton gave up his job as a
journalist to retrain as a doctor in his
thirties
he'll tell us why he made such a a major
life change a half past nine
now police say they've significantly
reduced the number of so-called
county lines gangs smuggling drugs it
follows a week of raids across the
country
earlier this month well let's get
details from aisha zaheed who's in the
newsroom
for us this morning what do we know
aisha well these arrests were made
last week as part of national crackdown
on county line scans across the uk and
they involve various police forces
across the country
now as you said more than a thousand
arrests were made in that week beginning
the 17th of may
and just under 300 weapons were seized
as well in the crackdown which included
33
guns and 219 knives as well now
police say there are currently around
600 of these gangs
operating in the uk which is actually
down from about 2
000. now county lines gangs are
essentially
drug dealers who sell to customers based
in rural areas through dedicated phone
lines and
in these in this crackdown 80 of these
phone lines were discovered on seized
mobile phones
now these gangs often use vulnerable
adults as well as children
as drug mules to transport drugs and
often conceal and deal from their own
homes so police also visited 904
addresses of concern
and as a role as a result 1138
people are currently being safeguarded
so
police have also said that in the past
18 months they've made substantial
progress
in tackling these gangs on this crime
but it's hoped by focusing resources in
this way
and these kinds of crackdowns will help
tackle the problem
going forward thank you
now also in the headlines this morning a
gunman has shot dead eight workers at a
rail yard in california
it happened at the santa clara valley
transportation authority depot
near san jose we have eight victims
that are pronounced deceased from
today's incident from gunshot wounds
we also have one suspect who is deceased
as well
from this morning's incident i can
confirm with you that deputies did not
exchange gunfire
and right now we're going to preliminary
go with the assumption that it was a
self-inflicted gunshot wound from the
suspect
and deputies did not exchange gunfire at
this point
we have investigators on scene
interviewing anybody that was on scene
to see what exactly happened
a week-long lockdown has been ordered
for seven million people in australia
everyone in the state of victoria will
have to stay at home from tonight for
seven days
after a cluster of cases of coronavirus
officials in one canadian province say
they'll decide whether to lift their
lockdown depending on local vaccination
rates
the premier of alberta says restrictions
will be eased
for every 10 percent of the population
over 50 percent
which receives the jab
there's been disappointment for
manchester united as they lost the villa
real in the europa league final 22
shot penalty shootout ended when
the villarreal goalkeeper scored his
penalty before saving one
taken by the manchester united
goalkeeper
france has again tightened restrictions
on british travelers
entering the country it follows excuse
me concern about the spread of the
indian variant of kovid 19. let's talk
to our europe correspondent
adam parsons who's in brussels for us
this morning i mean
just what exactly are the french
authorities saying
so we're going to get full details later
today stephen but
what we are expecting is that france
will say
that there will be no uk visitors
allowed through unless they have an
essential purpose
such as being a resident and that those
who do come through will have to produce
a pcr
test uh that is no more than and we are
awaiting this either 36 or 48 hours old
at the moment
it's 72 hours and the people who come in
will then have to self
isolate for again we wait to protect
chilly seven days or even ten days
now at the moment when you go into
france you are asked
to quarantine uh for a week but frankly
it is not checked upon
this time they're making it quite clear
that there will be police checks and
there will be
hefty fines on those who break the rules
and it follows as you said the the
increasing anxiety here on the european
continent about this
indian variant germany has also
tightened its controls on uk visitors
insisting
on a two-week quarantine now
this announcement from france sort of
came out dribs and drabs
yesterday will be confirmed later on
with those
precise details but i think it does
reflect to that concern
and also this lingering worry about what
they call reciprocity here it's a word
you hear quite often
and you discuss covid restrictions the
french the germans and others point to
the fact that if they
visit the uk then they are subject to a
10-day quarantine so they say
it's not that surprising that those
coming from the uk
into the european mainland face their
own form of quarantine but for many
of course those who have been looking
forward to a summer holiday it will come
as a
as a disappointment france had pointedly
loosened its restrictions for visitors
not so long ago had taken away that
requirement for an essential purpose
and it also creates a division in europe
where you have france or germany now
tightening restrictions while company
while countries like spain are opening
their
arms to welcome uk visitors
adam thank you
now it's one of the most popular shows
in tv history and today
17 years after heading off to a new life
friends
is back since it's ended it's become one
of the most downloaded shows in britain
and the new reunion program is now
available on sky
is our entertainment reporter claire
gregory
oh my god here we go it was an
incredible
time everyone was so perfectly cast
it's the one friends fans have been
waiting for and those of us who've been
to reunions know they can be woefully
disappointing but the difference with
this group of mates getting back
together
is they reportedly made around 1.5
million pounds each
i remember i went to the producer of the
show i was on and he said that show's
not gonna make you a star
you'll see guest stars you'll see
surprises
you'll see the six of us in the same
room for the first time in
at least nine years if not 17. a lot of
laughs a lot of um
you know heartfelt moments and and it's
been
incredible the final episode broke
records when it aired 17 years ago
and the show quickly became the most
streamed in the uk when it arrived on
netflix
four years ago you still can't escape
repeats but through a modern lens some
of the language jokes and a lack of
diversity
has been criticized but the show's
impact on modern culture
is undeniable its legacy includes the
term friend zone
catchphrase is like how are you doing
and its influence on other sitcoms like
how i met your mother and new girl
the reunion episode which features
guests such as lady gaga and david
beckham
is unscripted so the actors reminisce
rather than reprise their roles
they have lots of surprises lots of
chats you know
janice is back for an oh my god and
things like that there are some lovely
little moments
and even though it's indulgent i think
it still keeps it fresh it's still very
funny
there are clips of the old episodes i
think people will enjoy it more than
they think they will
no one told you it might not be the
reboot that fans of the series were
really hoping for
but the reunion episode will be there
for tv audiences hungry for nostalgia
and escapism claire gregory sky news
fabulous i mean come on you can't say
you're not excited just to see what
they're gonna say
i am now just before we have a look at
the weather with joe take a look at this
and greece has seen some of the best
views of a combined
lunar eclipse and super moon
of course very red as a result of all of
that more than two thousand miles
uh from two thousand two hundred
thousand miles from earth
someone's written two thousand miles
from earth that would be a bit worried
uh it was seen
rising behind the greek temple of
poseidon
beautiful what a colour and actually the
moon driving down this morning because
you told me to look out for it yesterday
the moon was looking pretty big here as
well
oh absolutely extraordinary the thing is
it swaps place with the sun so quickly
as well if you happen to be around
because obviously
we're only three weeks away from the
longest day now so
the moon was there huge in the sky
lighting everything up and then replaced
by the sun
and it was very much 50 50 situation
love that moon absolutely beautiful
well of course we are very close to the
longest day uh it's been one of the
wettest
maze on record but things are improving
for the bank holiday weekend let's take
a look
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello good morning to you so what we've
got is low pressure to the west low
pressure to the east and that kind of
gives us this
little bit of nothingness in the middle
not as good as high pressure in control
but certainly
not bad we're going to pull up this
warmth for a start temperatures topping
20 degrees celsius
over much of the bank holiday weekend
but at times cloud
and rain threatening from the west or
the northwest and that's very much the
situation today
this cloud rolls in across ireland it's
going to bring some patchy rain with it
much of the uk mainland starting off
really nice today some fog to get rid of
and some low cloud on the eastern coast
but once that's gone sunshine a little
bit of fair weather cloud bubbling up as
time goes on and the risk of one or two
isolated showers
over northern england and out towards
the east as well
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
joe thank you still to come on sky news
breakfast westminster is still
buzzing following the extraordinary
appearance of dominic cummings before
mps yesterday we'll look into it in a
bit more detail
in just a couple of minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's an amazing feeling you never go
into writing something
and and ever expecting that it could
reach as many
people as this song has it's uh it's
been quite amazing
it was just written as a 45 second tv
theme song and there was some
radio disc jockey that kept getting
requests to play it on her program so
he just looped it three times in a row
to try to make it the length of a pop
song
and that's when warner brothers records
came back to me and said uh we better
write a full-length version of this song
and put it on the rembrandt's album
i used to go to the filmings of the show
it was kind of a family affair
uh my wife at the time was one of the
creators of the show marta kaufman
and um i used to bring my children to
the set on friday nights when we would
film the show in front of a live
audience
and in the beginning uh they would bring
the cast out to introduce them to the
audience
uh playing the theme song and
one night early on the whole audience
did the four hand claps
in the right spot song is being played
and i went oh my god we've got
lightning in a bottle here somehow
people have been dying for this cast to
get back together ever since the show
went off the air so
it's really like a such a sense of
healing it's it's like seeing your best
friends get back together again
um and while they will not be portraying
those characters
just seeing the actors together and
feeling the emotions of how much they
mean to each other
is i think is going to be quite moving
[Music]
[Music]
other housing secretary robert generic
has rejected claims that matt hancock
lied about his handling of the pandemic
former downing street advisor dominic
cummings alleged the health secretary
lied on multiple occasions
when he appeared before a parliamentary
committee yesterday
now a short time ago the housing
secretary said he didn't recognize those
claims
that's not my experience my experience
having worked with the health secretary
and with the prime minister
last year were of people doing
everything that they could under huge
pressure
in a unique situation to try to steer
the country through
the pandemic and every turn trying to
act in the best interests of the whole
country
that's of course what we would have
expected of them and that's what they
did
were the things that we could have done
differently or better i'm sure that
there were
let's talk to our political
correspondent tamara cohen who's in
westminster what do you make of that
tomorrow
well i think you can see the government
trying to rally around matt hancock
to an extent i mean he said he wasn't
his experience perhaps they're not the
most ringing endorsement
i think we'll be interested to see what
the prime minister says about that
when he appears later this morning he's
going to a hospital where no doubt he'll
be asked about this
matt hancock himself is going to be
taking questions in the house of commons
today his team
say he absolutely rejects what dominic
cummings said about him which
essentially is that
he should have been fired 20 times
because he lied about ppe he lied about
testing
and about about testing of people going
into care homes
and that everyone was getting the
treatment that they needed now dominic
cummings did not provide any evidence of
this and
we wait to see what matt hancock has to
say about it but
you can see government ministers saying
everyone was working as hard as they
could with the knowledge that they had
at the time
that we now know a lot more about covert
than we did then and so
obviously in hindsight things could have
been done differently but i think what
will be very difficult to brush off
is what dominic cummings says was a
complete failure of the system
all the key decision makers all the
plans he says we're getting everything
wrong
and that is going to be more difficult
for the government to dig its way out of
okay tomorrow thank you well of course
there were more than
seven hours of questions and answers
yesterday and
dominic cummings painted a very negative
picture of the way the government
handled the pandemic let's talk to
professor susan michie who's director
of the university college london center
for behaviour change and he's also a
member of sage and
independent sage good to see you this
morning
did any of the testimony yesterday um
sort of tick any boxes for you did you
recognize any of what was being said
well obviously i don't know what goes on
at the heart of government
but he did paint a very depressing
picture
and as a scientist uh spending a lot of
my last year
along with many many other colleagues
spending
hours a week on thinking about science
writing about science providing
scientific advice
on top of our day jobs it's quite
depressing to think
that all that work and all the many
reports that we've produced
weren't landing and possibly weren't
being considered
so i mean but i mean from what you've
seen
and from how the things worked out
during the pandemic do you think that is
the case do you think that your advice
was ignored
i think one of the frustrations
about um having given scientific advice
over this last year
is that there isn't feedback as to
whether the fact that some of our advice
isn't acted on
is because it was rejected
it wasn't thought to be good or maybe
there are other political priorities
um so one never really knows what the
explanation is
when the advice we give isn't being
implemented
and i think that's a shame because i
think it's quite demoralizing for
scientists
but also i think it's important for the
public to know
how taxpayers money is being spent
because obviously
um there's a substantial expense to um
serving a big scientific infrastructure
so i think it's
really helpful for everyone to know
the extent to which scientific advice is
being used
but but in general in terms of what i
mean we've been told throughout this
pretty much that that we're being led by
the science now we know that's not
always the case and the you know
the economy has to have a very big say
in all of this as well i mean there are
lots of different factors
to consider but but in the course of the
pandemic have there been some glaring
incidences which you think
you know that the government has not
acted in the best interest of what sage
has been telling them
well there are several examples of where
the scientific advice wasn't followed
and i've worked with policy makers in
government
for decades and i would never expect
policy makers
um to follow the science hope is they
will be
informed by the science um an example i
think where
the advice was side stepped was
um the moving from a two meter rule to a
one meter plus rule
and um sage didn't waver from its advice
that two meters is significantly
safer but in that instance um instead of
saying well actually we're not going to
follow that advice for these reasons ie
be transparent about the process
instead um the prime minister said he
set up a dining street review of some
scientists and economists
and then on the basis of that they
changed to one meter plus
but we were never told who were the
people on that
review what evidence did they look at
how did they come to their conclusions
and so that's an example where uh when
the science didn't suit
um the government sidestepped it uh
without any transparency and i think
that's unfortunate
i mean do you think i mean there's lots
of calls for a public inquiry to be held
sooner than spring next year we
understand all the arguments involved in
that but
but when it does happen do you think we
are going to get that transparency
i actually think we need an inquiry as
soon as possible
and actually it takes the best part of
the year to set up an inquiry to
um get the chair the members in place
the terms of reference the scope agreed
etc um so this should be being done
right now if there's any
chance of it even starting next spring
and i haven't heard that any of this
preparatory work is being done and
hearing about the lack of preparation
and planning
um from mr cummings yesterday makes me
very concerned
about this inquiry is it that they're
going to start thinking about it
next spring which would mean it wouldn't
start till the year after which means
it won't it won't come to any
conclusions for many many years
so i think this is really urgent and it
does need to be
transparent i think the lack of
transparency is a real problem
because first of all it means there's
not the
public and scientific scrutiny and
accountability
and but also it means there's less trust
by everyone
and trust is such an important thing
during a pandemic when we want everybody
to pull together
so that we can get out of this as soon
as possible
susan mitchell really good to talk to
you thank you pleasure
okay let's talk to former parliamentary
sketch writer andrew jameson who's
written a book about boris johnson good
to see you this morning do you think
that the evidence yesterday will prove
to be damaging not only to to the prime
minister and the health secretary in
particular but to the
the way the government has operated
throughout this pandemic
i thought the evidence was highly
convincing cummings
claimed he wasn't telling the whole
truth he was telling part of the truth
and
we all know the government was
disgracefully unprepared for this
pandemic and elementary things like
producing enough
um protective personal equipment i mean
where i live people actually went round
to the local hospital and started making
it themselves
we really should have uh uh have been
ready to
deal with problems elementary problems
like that and we weren't and cummings
was quite right about that yeah what i
mean what why do you think you
you believed a lot of what he said i
mean he is in some respects a man
out for revenge isn't it the man who's
been scorned
he is and i think that's one reason why
it probably won't damage the government
that much because
if there's one person who people in the
wider
um country have heard of it's dominic
cummings and many people are so
extremely angry about um his
his expedition to daruman to barnard
castle so
i think actually and and also it's a bit
like
this oddly enough i think the psychology
is a bit like the second world war
in the second world war we had all sorts
of appalling disasters
for several years um not only under
neville chamberlain but under winston
churchill and then
we won the war and everyone felt so glad
that we won the war of course so sad at
the terrible casualty which would occur
but the the the joy of winning
um somehow eclipsed the anger
at the extreme waste of life and
and so on which had occurred uh as we
worked our way as we learned how to win
that victory and i think
something of the same feeling people
feel so good about the vaccinations
that they are to some extent prepared to
forgive
um the the terrible mistakes which were
made earlier also
cummings is always repair making this
comparison between
what happened and some sort of rather
illusory idea of a perfect response
which admittedly he says you know they
did it very very well in taiwan
and we weren't prepared to learn from
taiwan and south korea
um and singapore um but
the wider public know that life is never
perfect the government makes terrible
mistakes
as long as it learns from them and the
learning in this
case may have been rather slow but as
long as it does and the whole thing
turns out all right in the end
terrible loss of life then i mean the
polls suggested at the moment
people are not trying to turn sort of
boris johnson into the neville
chamberlain of the
pandemic yeah i mean is dominic cummings
playing a political game here
whether he's making some valid points or
not the fact is you know
going for the prime minister going for
matt hancock but
you know being quite nice about dominic
rob and not criticizing particularly
uh rishi sunak i mean but is he playing
politics here
there is an element of politics and he
does tend to divide the word
world into heroes and villains so
that's undeniable i think oddly enough i
think it's rather to boris johnson's
credit that these arguments were going
on in number 10
even if the wrong side sometimes won he
i think he johnson does like to be
surrounded by very able people and
cummings is
palpably very very able and won't get
into grips with the science
um although he's quite modest about his
own scientific attainment and was
bringing
in very very clever people to challenge
the group think and the
there is always a danger of group
thinking these things and i think
cummings is completely right that the
scientific evidence um should generally
be presented so
it can be reviewed by other scientists
uh we can all see what the arguments are
that they're
making but the i returned to the point
that the public know that
this was an incredibly difficult thing
to deal with
um the people dealing with it were under
enormous pressure
and the public is not going to be quite
as quite as
sensorious as cummings is yeah i mean
look
we know that in in terms of playing
politics
people tend to like a sacrificial lamb
it doesn't look like the prime minister
is going to be too badly damaged by this
in some respects as you said
but what about matt hancock well
hancock acts from johnson's point of
view as a valuable
diversion i think and johnson won't
throw hancock off the sledge johnson in
fact has been very
reluctant to throw anyone off the stage
for any reason however
strong because he knows that the feral
beasts
uh in the media as soon as we've got um
one um
one one bloody corpse um
we want another one so um it doesn't do
any good um
but i mean that that's that's rather
comforting i think for
for johnson that hancock on this
occasion has had to soak up a lot of the
pressure
andrew good to talk to you thank you
thank you
i just want to bring you some breaking
news relating to the vaccine rollout and
health officials in northern ireland
have just announced the program is now
open
to everyone they say the booking system
will now accept details for anyone
aged over 18.
now one of britain's leading military
charities is warning veterans will find
it increasingly difficult to work after
they leave the forces
the forces in mind trust says many
employers misunderstand
what types of skills that ex-service
personnel have
ashna huradak reports
eleven years ago fiona left the royal
air force and stepped
into civilian life but for five years
she struggled to find work
despite an adaptable skill set you are
perhaps worse off than someone who's had
four years of work experience post
university
in the civilian world you're having to
relearn all this stuff that
i really must admit i i didn't think i'd
need because i thought i was
sorted for life frankly and that
whatever came along post forces would be
able to benefit from that kudos and that
experience
when you leave early the rug is pulled
out from underneath you
the changing face of conflict means the
work of the armed forces is increasingly
technology-based
our adversaries have become skilled at
undermining us by exploiting
the gray zone while maintaining the
threat of conventional hard power
with disinformation intimidation and
cyber hacks
weapons of choice
the role of those on this invisible
front line mean skills are easily
misunderstood
and overlooked a leading charity
is warning there will be more veterans
like fiona in the coming decades
who may be left behind throughout their
service careers they need to be
uh getting the civilian qualifications
they need to be exposed to civilian
workplaces through
through job placement exercises there
needs to be a much closer link between
armed forces personnel and their
families
and civilian society the communities
they're going to retire into
so these are all actions which need to
be improved upon
the psychological effects of working in
this murky evolution of warfare
is also unknown the infrastructure of
support they argue
needs to be rethought what our challenge
is
is actually get getting businesses and
organizations to recognize
um what our armed forces actually have
to offer because
you know the size of armed forces is
very very smaller uh than they have been
in the
number of decades therefore people's
absolute appreciation of what our
veterans offer
perhaps isn't so uh obvious
only few understand the trials of the
transition
and many of them say more support is
needed to help this league of men and
women
find their identity in civilian society
ashley harinag sky news
of course as we've been saying a lot of
the focus on the dominic cummings
evidence yesterday was based around
matt hancock a man who should have been
fired 15 to 20 times says mr cummings
well
matt hancock's not got a lot to say this
morning
mr hancock
does the country allow that country
to drive forward the vaccine program and
then i'll be going to the house of
commons and i'll answer questions there
thanks very much
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
not a bad day in store today plenty of
dry weather for the uk mainland
although it will be a little bit misty
and murky over eastern coast to start
off with
later in the day we see some patchy rain
working its way in across ireland
and it'll be making its way eastwards
but slow progress
temperatures between 17 and 21 degrees
celsius so warmer than it has been
and technically we're in the grass
pollen season now although there is
still some tree pollen around
levels are likely to be moderate through
the south but low across the rest of the
country
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
now after a week of raids across the
country police say they've significantly
reduced the number of so-called
county lines gangs smuggling drugs let's
talk to national police chief council
and deputy assistant commissioner of the
metropolitan police grain
mcnulty good to see you this morning
explain to us for those of us who don't
know
quite what county lines are and how they
operate
good morning well county lines is a
abhorrent crime type where drug dealers
in the cities
are exploiting young people and
vulnerable adults to
send drugs across the country and
they're making a profit from it
we see significant levels of violence
and we also see exploitation
um so this week was really focused on
targeting the people behind the line
the line holders the individuals taking
the profit out of drug dealing
and we're really pleased we've had over
1100 arrests
we've closed down 80 lines um and
officers across the country from every
force
have worked incredibly hard to keep our
communities safe so i'm really pleased
it's clearly been a very big operation i
mean how how long in the planning is
something like this
so something like this takes a long time
and it's quite quick for me to give you
those headline figures isn't it but i'm
very conscious
um police officers as a staff have put a
lot of preparation in
and even now after we've made those
arrests they'll be working hard to put
cases together for the crown prosecution
service
and to go to court so many months in the
making but
it's a real priority for us and despite
the pandemic
and the issues that policing has had to
face county lines has remained a focus
for us all during this time
yeah i mean what what impact has the
pandemic had i mean obviously you've you
know
the police force have had other
priorities
so so we have but i i think policing has
been agile and
and we've responded to the way county
lines has changed so
um coaches haven't been running um
obviously trains have been a lot quieter
to the footfall
we've seen some movement into cars for
dealing lines and taking drugs across
the country
um and we've responded to that and we've
looked at the changing tactics
and i think the results from this week
show that we've been successful in
reducing the amount of county lines
yeah but what for moving forward though
because i mean
as successful as this appears to have
been
it it's an ongoing battle isn't it well
stephen it is an ongoing battle
and we we changed our operating model uh
about 18 months ago
and that is showing real success and
we've seen a number of county lines
which
we thought were active to from about 2
000 coming down to around 600 now so
that's a big
um reduction and we're focusing more on
modern slavery offenses
so these individuals they're not just
drug dealers they're child traffickers
and we're now not only arresting from
their drug dealing but we're also
arresting them
for those slavery offences and putting
them before the courts
and of course there are longer sentences
there and there are orders we can use
that control them long
you know long after their sentence has
has finished so i'm hopeful that we can
change this distribution model
um and we really can dismantle county
lines i mean
how important is is public intervention
in all of this you know
people effectively operating as
informants giving you tip-offs let you
know it letting you know what is going
on
so of course we we police by consent and
we rely on the public for all sorts of
crime types and
and this is no different and you know i
would appeal to your viewers
now um to look out for the signs of a
young person possibly being exploited
you know are they out during school
hours on a train or traveling
um are we seeing young people with train
tickets to venues they shouldn't be
going to
suddenly getting an expensive phone or
an expensive pair of trainers
how did they get that is is someone
giving them these gifts in turn for
them doing you know drug dealing on
their behalf and we want to protect our
young generation and i would
i would really implore everyone out
there if you see a young person and
you're worried about them
you can contact the police you can
contact crime stoppers and we want to
stop this exploitation
i mean in terms of i mean you you
mentioned the exploitation obviously the
drugs there's the the modern slavery
issue
as well but i mean people are going to
be concerned about it because these
these people are presumably quite
dangerous i mean they're dealing with
things that involve an
awful lot of money and we know that
carries a lot of a lot of danger as well
you're right we do see a cycle of drugs
weapons and violence and that's why it's
such a priority for us
i'm in particular we see very serious
crimes linked to county lines and
serious youth violence which is why
we want people to talk to us give us
information and why we want to protect
young people from getting involved in
the first place
if we can prevent them from ever going
near a county line
then we've really done our job and we
will really focus
on tackling those line holders the
people behind the line
who leave a trail of misery behind them
but are happy to take the profit out of
it
do you think you get enough support in
dealing with this i mean on the basis
the very nature of how they operate is
is you know to do it covertly so it's
not something which makes the headlines
very often um do you get enough support
in trying to tackle with this
these sort of underlying concerns so one
of the things that i have benefited from
since i've been involved in this for the
past two years is significant investment
and that has enabled us to set up three
task forces one in liverpool
one in the west midlands and one in
london and those three areas are
responsible
for eighty percent of our county lines
but that focus and those dedicated
resources has really helped us to make
this difference
and get the results that we're talking
about today so
um that investment has helped and it's
also enabled us to work more closely
together so
it's a cross-border crime it goes across
the whole of the country
but what i'm seeing firsthand now is the
big exporting forces
working really closely with the
importing forces and the way to beat
county lines is to tackle both ends of
the line at the same time
simultaneously and that's what we're
seeing and then
joint enforcement joint case preparation
and that's how we'll defeat this drugs
distribution model
deputy assistant commissioner good to
talk to you thank you thank you
okay this is sky news breakfast let's
have a look at the weather for you
with joe
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you all the
sunshine is streaming through the window
here
in london and many other parts too it is
going to be a lovely day
it's a little bit grey along eastern
coast this morning low cloud has rolled
in from the north sea
and ireland not faring so well either
there's a frontal system making its way
in
it will be fairly light and patchy but
uh still rather a gray day to come
so this is the way things look first
they're off we've got a little bit of
mist and fog around over western areas
the sunshine should soon put pay to that
and also that low cloud in the east that
should burn back
otherwise we're looking at sunshine
fairly light winds and temperatures
higher than they have been recently
certainly an area from manchester down
towards the southeast we could see
20-22 degrees celsius that's 72 degrees
fahrenheit
fairweather cloud building up a few
showers breaking out over northern
england
that those are melt away later along
with the cloud but throughout the day
ireland really not having such a good
day of it rather overcast with those
outbreaks of rain
the weather sponsored by qatar airways